you love them I love them but is it love
for Shawn Mendes and Camila Kibeho the
pair brought their romance to Florida
this weekend and et has all the details
check them out arm-in-arm at Oxford
Exchange in Tampa and here sipping
coffee chatting one-on-one o to be a fly
on the Hat ball et has learned they also
went to Bahama Breeze in Tampa on Friday
and obviously we have eyewitness deets
because our news desk was really working
overtime this weekend you're welcome
we've learned quote they were being
flirty with each other and they were
kissing she had her hand on his leg
[Music]
now this isn't the first time Camila has
joined Shaun on the road she also joined
him in California earlier this month
last week Shaun dodged a question about
Camila though the bear has seemingly
been dating since around the time their
senior video came out but neither has
confirmed it which is a little weird
since in 2015 when people also thought
they were dating
they were both quick to well deny it
record straight no we are just friends
for Edinson we're not dating
yeah we're just friends he's like one of
my best friends but it's hard to deny
cold hard proof
just saying alright guys what do you
think are we gonna get a confirmation
from them anytime soon what do you love
most about them together let me know
let's chat and for all the latest on
Sean and Camila keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now